hello and welcome to this video playing
Elm chicks la animal that's probably not
going to be right yeah
give me that hey what's that
a three okay
a three yeah whatever
I mean black and white can do all kinds
of stuff all right
to think this combination of moves makes
all that much sense yep
okay that's a ticket I mean it's just
giving me a three and whatever that I
just it's weird
and it should be enough to be better
with black interesting now I can
completely kill a spawn structure
Wow
all right now what
play this bishop
six books eh
yeah I guess so
Oh
hmm there is possible absolutely
and I don't lie
we'd like him to take down that I could
not allow
so you wonder where exactly White's King
is going to be placed
now we know okay some night here at
centralized F 494 is bad for white I
think and in general group c8 would
probably just win c3
not strategically disastrous really but
okay so CF is he going f5 or
yeah let's just just stop all this
we a 23 I know I'm going to do that
so don't have to do anything too fancy
just not get checkmated basically as
what I need to do so if I take
ship g6
you
yeah
you
mmm it is actually a move
you
hmm yeah that should have probably
played differently
I still think it's quite good but it's
not as good as it was
ma'am it's getting is getting some kind
of initiative him now how do we how do
we handle that
cautious about possible discoveries
you
you
you
not certain about this
it was the best assume and
six but now I recognize that 93 is
actually quite okay for white that I
shouldn't have done
you
yeah that was bad badly played
neither three are thought hmm yeah maybe
he's got night aged 3 to f4
but to have 16 seconds 16 seconds is not
much
to
for some some sacrifice
mere maybe with eight seconds
you
eight-second Sam how do I get into those
messes yeah from positions that are just
over I would of the opening probably I'm
spending too much time here for full
refutations and then when I'm stuck
when I don't really find a full
refutation
brookey five
[Music]
it's just so awful against this
completely sorry idiotic opening where
I'm just winning a mere limb
and it's so awful
scam oh my god oh my god
hmm come on they don't get me started on
this I mean
this is why I don't keep this rating we
have this source completely idiotic
games it's winning after move 12 him and
then I spoil this frigging thing if I
did I waste all the freaking time him I
mean this is so awful
it's spirit I can take a three whatever
basically everything wins any of course
this is also still completely winning
but yeah I managed to spoil it
yeah yeah I know I'm down to a minute
weather minute I should so comfortably
win this really and probably just again
two simple things
I am 95 it's just too fancy you mean
yeah I can obviously just take twice and
boy him this is like really wanting to
play a play strategically nicely and
things are
things are tricky now
that I can take you 6m
yeah I can take you six and by now I'm
on eight second so I don't really blame
myself and yeah Bishop g6 was winning
Kade and see it
but position is already completely lost
learning yeah I was kind of clear that
they were blunders him King King d5 is a
draw I have 12 seconds yeah I don't know
I didn't even look it didn't look any
more kinky fibers of what was a draw I
mean the way he played I probably would
have won that easily but objectively
it's a draw
it's just so awful I'm just opening I
mean crazy
crave completely crazy opening
he has said two minutes that is what
really annoys me it's not like I spent
ages before I like winning Nintendo's
also I said I had two minutes and it's
this is also something that I considered
and it is also very convincing actually
just put this here play six I mean then
then week week week
everything is weak so you don't just
don't get checkmate again
anyway thanks for watching guys